starting off with a fox news alert here
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas is leading a congressional
delegation to see the conditions at our
southern border firsthand today
and get an update on the unaccompanied
children coming to the border
however one person is notably absent
from the trip
vice president harris today marks her
45th straight day without a news
conference on the border since taking on
a leading role to deal with the crisis
but even with the vice president m.i.a
the crisis is real
border patrol agents in south texas
arresting 180 migrants at three stash
houses near the border
customs and border protection says they
came from mexico el salvador and
guatemala
meanwhile we are seeing the number of
ice deportations shrinking down 20
from march to april while the department
of health and human services reports
there were nearly 22
000 unaccompanied minors in its custody
as of may
5th pete this is on the heels of course
of the president saying it's being
managed and it's declined but we all
know
those numbers are simply absorbed
elsewhere in the system
not to mention the over 18 000 migrant
children
that have been put into the custody of
people in all 50 states and puerto rico
where is the vice president well she's
not there she's not going there anytime
soon she has
shirked her responsibility from the very
beginning and of course he goes down
there now that they've emptied out those
border facilities and as you mentioned
spread them all around the country this
is not
the numbers you mentioned don't even
mention the amount of illegal crossings
that have occurred that we can't account
for because all of our time has been
spent
focusing on uh unaccompanied minors who
are crossing and now we're talking about
potentially reuniting
those might bringing the families from
those countries to reunite with the
miners talk about an incentive
plus deportations are at record lows ice
feels like their hands are completely
tied
if i'm the cartels the only
signal i'm seeing is business is good
not to mention the refugee cap being
raised to 125 000
so all things considered the only
messages border is open
kids are still my golden ticket families
might be able to join
them and then you they facilitate
spreading those kids across the country
just so that the dhs secretary can go to
the border
and showcase his newly uh wide-open
facilities the ones that they wouldn't
let us see when they were packed and
kaylee it appears that those in the
white house
are paralyzed while they try to discover
apparently for the first time what the
root causes are while ignoring all of
the pull factors from this country
there's just silence in the wake what
about the rest of us that are waiting
not only for an answer for
for an addressing for even just talking
about this topic and being open to
questions
let alone actually acting on it you know
emily i think it's
more than just silence what they are
doing with the border their
communications
is an insult to the american people they
have shown that this is
just not a serious endeavor for them
kamala was asked when are you visiting
the border
she laughed uh jen saki was asked
yesterday when's biden visiting the
border she said oh well americans don't
care about immigration so
essentially he's not going that's not a
serious answer and she went on to say
that what we're seeing
is cyclical fact check false it's not
cyclical in fact there's a 20-year high
of illegal immigrants coming to our
border and then you have
my orcas going to an empty facility the
donna facility
which the only reason it is empty is
because the kids have been moved to hhs
facilities as we discussed yesterday
and it is an all-time record high in
united states history
that we have 25 000 unaccompanied
children in federal custody
and what do they do they laugh they say
numbers are coming down they say it's
cyclical
and they don't visit our border so this
is not serious for them and it's an
insult to the american people and
they're making a huge mistake
because this is what helped president
trump get elected the first time the
border will be front and center
uh in two years and in four years
and rachel in the wake of this crisis of
this emergency the majority of those
children are now put into these
emergency shelters
which as we know because they're so
overflowing because everyone is so
overwhelmed
they have foregone background checks and
fingerprinting of staff and volunteers
they also don't require licensing they
don't require the same uh policy
uh conforming as the other shelters do
not to mention that it's more expensive
at 775 dollars per day per child
so what gets lost in all of that is the
care of the children
absolutely and by the way look at those
images i mean so much for
you know all the pandemic panic um we're
in the middle of this pandemic
supposedly and there's another variant
in brazil
and this is what we're seeing from the
biden administration who will lock down
our businesses but you're right
this comes right back to the children
these children
are being used as pawns for power and a
voter drive
by the democrat party and that is
exactly what's happened when people go
why is this happening that is why we
need to get to
why it's happening she is not coming
because she knows what the plan
is and she doesn't want to have her
fingerprints on it do you guys remember
when ted cruz
went to cancun when he was supposed they
said he was supposed to be in texas
during that emergency
um and by the way he was a federal uh
legislator who couldn't do anything
about it
this is kamala harris's job
and the media is giving her such a free
pass and the american people are seeing
it at least those who are watching our
channel
i tell you everybody else watching other
channels are not
seeing the images that we're seeing um
they've moved
they've moved on beyond on this crisis a
couple weeks ago on the other channels
but this is happening and the children
are the victims child trafficking
remains
a major problem and they have their
hands
um and their fingerprints on all of this
distress
and all of the things that are happening
to these children it is very very
sad